herr oettinger ich brauche ihre hilfe ja
wie gut waren sie in der schule
ich sage nichts flexit
[Musik]
die fritz gasen schule in berlin steckte
diesen sommer mitten in den
vorbereitungen auf den corona unterricht
und ausgerechnet dann kam zwei problemen
schüler vorbei der in einer woche öffnet
ja ihre schule wieder fühlen sie sich
gut vorbereitet als stellvertretender
schulleiter fühlt man sich in der
letzten woche vor der schule wie gut vor
ja wir haben einen hygieneplan es wurde
aber jetzt mehrfach in den medien
berichtet der hygieneplan wird noch mal
überarbeitet habe ich heute unsere
offiziellen schulen mails geguckt und
stellte fest bis jetzt gibt es keinen
offiziellen neuen hygieneplan und wir
müssen aber uns ja irgendwie auch auf
gegebenenfalls was neues vorbereiten
dazu muss ich wissen was von mir
erwartet wird glauben sie denn dass es
hier hygienisch zugeht
auf jeden fall deutlich weniger als von
aber es ist schon so dass man als lehrer
jetzt auch warum unterricht für sich
meint unter die dusche stellt nicht nur
weil man lehrer geworden ist sondern
waren wir einfach sauber werden
nein also so weit würde ich nicht also
soweit war es bei mir ehrlich gesagt nur
was halten sie denn von der
kultusministerkonferenz ich wäre
eigentlich dafür dass er sich irgendwann
mal unnötig macht aber ich dagegen bin
dass wir 16 verschiedener lehrpläne
haben in
[Musik]
ihr habt ihr jetzt eine menge schlau
angestellt mir stelle ich euch mal ein
paar schlaue fragen und zwar für jeden
bitte ohne hilfsmittel ohne anrufen 45
minuten zeit
ich sag euch gleich wenn es losgeht für
fabian habe ich mir englisch ausgesucht
ok und für den habe ich mich mit
mathematik klar hatte ich schon erwähnt
das ist jahrgangsstufe sieht es also das
dürfte nicht überfordern oder auf die
plätze fertig los
[Musik]
so in der ahnung 0 ich habe eine idee
ja herr lauterbach hält aber sie müssen
mir helfen ich bin ja gerade in der
prüfung
wie gut sind sie in mathe einigermassen
ja immer wieder reißt plus wieso jetzt
ernsthaft ja du weißt doch jünger das
ist mir egal sind flaschen wein zurück
jetzt hat der nutzer lauterbach wir
nehmen ich denn als türke englisch herr
oettinger ich brauche ihre hilfe ja wie
gut waren sie in der schule ich gar
nicht zulässig
das heißt ganz konkret in mathematischen
1 in französisch 43 das ist schlecht
denn es geht hat sich um englisch ich
schwitze hier ziemlich an der english
aufgabe siebte klasse lernstandserhebung
oder siebte klasse aufgabe ja ich komme
nicht weiter
ich lese ihnen die aufgabe vor
konzentrieren sie sich meine zeit ist
hier auch begrenzt sie müssen wir jetzt
helfen
bauer klein hat 16 kühe und fünf kälber
am morgen beginnt der bauer um 445 mit
dem melken er benötigt dafür insgesamt
40 minuten jede kuh gibt pro tag
ungefähr 30 liter milch wir sollten
einen dialog zwischen lehrer und schüler
ins englische übersetzen meinen sie wir
kriegen das zusammen hin
okay okay wenn das schon so anfängt dann
habe ich wirklich angst ein sack mit 100
kilogramm kraftfutter kostet 20 euro
der bauer hat noch 24 säcke im vorrat
wann ist der bau mit dem melken fertig
gibt die uhrzeit an
es kann so schnell wieder erleben sie
was zum schreiben nehmen sich schnell
was zum schreiben
es geht los mit dem lehrer part ja bitte
erst hieß naja ok gut wäre ich doch auch
eigentlich auch noch gekommen die zeit
rennt herr lauterbach
dann lese ich noch mal langsam vor
nehmen sie irgendwas jetzt müssen sie
sagen steht an der tafel kennt sieht vor
dass unsere front of yes bauer klein
obwohl das der name ist egal schreiben
so bäuerin klöckner es ist es ist egal
hat und ich sage warum sind die schulen
nicht saniert der unterricht nicht
digitalisiert und an die scheuer immer
noch verkehrsminister der mobile yours
to win situation weil nobody does and
investment bei friendly fire is ongoing
release doch vor dem kauf von vdo im
curling berechnet wie viel geld der
bauer für den verkauf von 350 litern
milch erhält das haben sie doch eben
aufgeschrieben aber was sagen sie denn
warum sind die schulen immer noch nicht
saniert der unterricht immer noch nicht
digitalisiert lässt jedes aber german
and increasing dapd interessiert teilte
ihm rest in die kita technologies and
infrastructure zur school spirit
highschools kindergartens swr des
kindergartens haben sie richtig gut
ausgesprochen kann der bauer seine kühe
auch einfach antonius verkaufen und sich
von dem geld urlaub auf malle buchen
main nach werden können ist gehört haben
soll ich das so hin schreiben wer will
die schimmel kühe dankeschön dass vielen
dank herr oettinger dass wir jetzt frage
h rechnet man bei der spd überhaupt noch
mit zahlen über 15 also zumindest nicht
was es war alles klar
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist ein minimal hersteller